foreign
Finance YouTuber told his followers they
should be able to easily afford a two
hundred thousand dollar car he called it
literal literally Pocket Change
um hey we have a clip for it we're gonna
show the clip okay let's show the clip
let's roll it if you're a guy in your
20s and you don't have a Lamborghini you
should actually sit down and have like a
serious discussion with yourself as to
why you don't have a Lambo because it's
I realize now that it's so incredibly
easy and there's so much money out there
and 200 Grand relative to what is out
there in circulation and what you can
grab especially now with AI tools that
you can leverage like never before 200
Grand is chump change
200 Grand is chump change which as you
can imagine he's just gotten blasted
um for being a privileged whatever
whatever turns out his
um parents immigrated to this country
when he when they were teenagers he was
raised in a very low income and worked
at Taco Bell he's literally
if his if his story is to be believed
earned this money yeah so yeah self-made
and literally started from nothing and
probably in the tech world you know
whatever he's doing job-wise I don't
even know
um yeah has made this okay so I have
like just polar opposite reactions in my
head because at first I'm like dude like
who what no yeah like that's no no
that's not chump change like 200 000
because you look at what the average
American spends I mean and we deal with
you know everyday people on the show and
it's like man you know they they're
they're living paycheck to paycheck and
all of it so household income
yeah that's my that's like my first
reaction but then you hear a story and
you're like man
you know immigrants that come to this
country
uh they say you know build wealth and I
don't have the stat right but I think
it's like five times faster if they come
legally versus just someone that's born
here in the States because that because
that's the other that's the other
argument is I'm like okay so he sees
opportunity he comes he sees it
everywhere everywhere and he's like how
could you not be making so much money
because there is so much out there to be
made to be made and there's so much
opportunity of of course you're gonna be
making a ton because you can right like
that's his mindset uh so when I when I
worked at universities for all those
years I um all my International students
uh I would always like do sessions and
we would hang out we'd have lunch
together and we would they were part of
my classes
it was always amazing to me how my
International International students
that came in they were so wide-eyed with
opportunity they just saw it everywhere
it was it was wild and they they
inspired me I remember 10 15 years ago
you're missing this whole thing right
you are so focused on getting this one
job with this one salary so that you can
meet some sort of internal and I was
just missing opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity after
opportunity and so it really it inspired
me years ago
um that I they just gave me a new set of
glasses with which to see the world and
so I see this and you got a guy whose
parents immigrated over here as
teenagers grew up with almost nothing
and now yes I would tell him if he was
my friend don't say that out loud right
I know I know don't say that out oh you
sound like an idiot but but also
man if you were able to sit down and see
the world and say there's so much
opportunity what do you like get up and
go find the opportunity go make it
happen go make it right make it happen
it's inspiring I mean in that sense
right and and again I hate that a Lambo
was his example I wish it was like go
get a 200 000 house they're like you
know what I mean something that feels a
little give 200 000 away but it's it's
it's the sentiment out there is
isn't true I mean it is it's inspiring
it I mean when you think about it that
way you're like man what what else can I
be doing but I think too we can get in
that mindset of like just pilot money
pilot money pilot money make more make
more make more make more make more but
there is more to life than just that
equation right and so
um all that plays in as well so there's
there's many different angles I think
this this kind of story for me is is as
important as somebody like cam Haynes or
David goggin somebody who's running
marathons every day or running 200 mile
races whatever
the average person's not going to do
that but when you have these
um pacesetters out there who are doing
these amazing things it makes me when I
want to skip my 30 minute workout or my
60 Minute Workout in the morning because
I don't feel like it or I'm too tired I
can't today
yeah I can yeah you know what I mean
yeah right or I just can't get ahead
it's just too hard I just can't find the
job
yeah you can right there is opportunity
somewhere and it might be doing stuff
you don't like like working at Taco Bell
I spent four years at Burger King like
it's not my it wasn't my dream job yeah
man I learned a lot of great lessons and
learned how to love and take care of
people even while asking them would you
like fries with them right and so yeah
it just reminds me of that abundance
um
it's just everywhere and if you change
that mindset it it does have it doesn't
solve your problems money doesn't go in
your bank account but you begin to look
at the world a little bit what is it
Henry Ford if you think you can if you
think you can't you can't you can't yeah
or it is what it is that's right so like
what you believe you know does have
fruition in your life I mean there is
power to that so you gotta go make it
happen so yeah that's great anyway
Sebastian
just in the future just don't get on the
internets and
tell people that 200 000 pocket change
and thank you for inspiring us to see
the world a little bit differently that
there's an opportunity everywhere